-Welcome, everybody,
to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you so much for watching.
What a show we have
for you tonight.
Oh, also, I'm going to debut
my new Zoom camera.
I have a new Zoom camera.
It doesn't quite work.
It's a little wide-angled
and it's weird-looking.
But -- You got to --
You got to try.
You got to try new things
and see what works and what
doesn't work and all that.
I hope everyone
is staying safe out there.
I know it's tempting to just
"enough's enough,"
but, yeah, you're doing
the right thing.
Wear masks, wear gloves, stay
home when you can,
social-distance,
do everything you can.
Let's get rid of this thing.
What a show.
I'll just run through it
real quick.
Martin Short,
the funniest human of all time.
Love him so much.
He's just on fire.
He's just the greatest.
I love him, love him, love him
so much.
Also, speaking of funny, I met
them as writers on "Late Night,"
and now they are just ruling
the world right now
and hitting home runs,
comedy home runs,
all over the place.
Bashir Salahuddin and
Diallo Riddle,
the creators of "South Side"
and also "Sherman's Showcase,"
which is having their
Black History Month spectacular,
airing this Friday.
Man, they are so funny.
It's unbelievable.
The special is great.
Quest is in it. It's awesome.
And to close it out, honey,
do you know who
the musical guest is tonight?
-No, I do not.
-Well, well, well.
Who's one of my favorites
of all time?
-Is that a trick question?
-No, no. I'm sorry.
But -- Our -- Mutually,
who is one of the first
few people that we listened to?
Well, no, no,
it's endless, endless.
-Oh, I know.
-Ready?
-Yes. I was going through
who hadn't --
-I know --
there's a lot of people.
-Yes.
-Randy Newman.
-Stop it.
-Randy Newman is tonight.
-Oh, this is a big one.
-I love Randy Newman.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And he's my man.
-Yeah, I just -- I don't know.
What a show.
Alright, let's get to
some news here.
Here we go.
Let's get right to it.
Today started off with some
big news from the Supreme Court.
-We have breaking news from
the Supreme Court.
It is a landmark decision
for the LGBTQ community.
The justices ruling that it is
illegal for workers
to be dismissed
from a job based on
sexual orientation
and gender identity.
-Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
It's 2020.
I thought good news was illegal.
Until this, the only good news
to come out of 2020
was Baby Nut.
Yeah, it's not the outcome
the Trump administration wanted.
Experts say it's the
most damaging thing to happen
to Trump in the
last...eight hours.
That was for watch,
wearing a watch.
People used to wear timepieces.
Yep, the decision protects
gay and transgender workers
from discrimination
in the workplace.
Unfortunately, thanks to Trump's
handling of the pandemic,
there is no workplace.
The court decided employers
can't fire workers
based on their sexual
orientation or gender identity.
They'll have to stick to
the usual reason workers
get fired -- not muting
themselves on Zoom.
The final vote was 6-3.
When he heard that, Trump said,
"Okay, what about
the Electoral College?"
Yep, it's a tough day for
the Trump administration.
We're just one more
"Will & Grace" reboot away
from this being the worst day
of Mike Pence's life.
The 6-3 opinion was written by
Trump-appointed justice
Neil Gorsuch.
Trump plans on punishing Gorsuch
by violently shaking
his hand again.
[ Applause ]
-What's he doing?
It's like he's trying to
start a lawnmower.
That's like -- You know who
would do those handshakes?
Kreskin would do that
when he came on the show.
And I always thought that was
part of the trick or something,
'cause I'd go, "Nice to see
you," and he'd go...
And he'd shake it
really hard and you'd go,
"Is this part of the -- Did
he just put something on my back
by distracting me?"
No, it's just the way
he shook hands.
Hi, Kreskin.
Well, everyone is
talking about this. Everybody.
Over the weekend,
President Trump
gave a commencement speech
at West Point,
but it looks like
he had some trouble leaving.
Take a look.
-You see him walking very
haltingly, one leg at a time.
It starts happening here.
Down a ramp.
-Yeah, apparently,
Trump was a little sensitive
about the incident,
because he then tweeted,
"The ramp that I descended
was very long and steep,
had no handrail,
and, most importantly,
it was very slippery.
Final 10 feet,
I ran down to level ground.
Momentum!"
Wow. Yep, that's about the only
momentum Trump has right now.
10 feet.
The last 10 feet, he ran?
[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
You know, there's so much
to say about the ramp video,
and I just can't pick one joke,
so I'm going to tell
as many jokes as I can
in the time it took Trump
to walk down that ramp.
You ready? Let's go.
He was just doing an impression
of his approval rating.
[ Ding ]
That was still faster than
his response to the coronavirus.
[ Ding ]
He broke his first
Fitbit record of 10 steps.
He looked like skier doing pizza
instead of French fries.
[ Ding ]
That's his audition tape for
"American Ninja Warrior."
It would be faster if
he sat at the top
and did a butt scooch down.
[ Buzzer ]
Oh! Alright. Alright.
I got some in there.
I had a couple more.
Want me to just tell you?
-Mm-hmm.
-He still hasn't realized
it's not an escalator.
[ Both laugh ]
That's right --
Trump said that the ramp
had no handrails
and was very slippery.
He really came down hard on it,
and I don't know if
he's going to let it go.
Check out this new attack ad
he just released.
-There's a new threat
in our country,
an enemy of the state
like we've never seen before...
the ramp.
We already know the ramp
is taking jobs
from hardworking
American stairs,
but who is the ramp really?
A known member of Antifa?
A foreign agent?
Or a deep-state Liberal elite?
Can we stop the spread
or is it already too late?
Paid for by
Americans Against Ramps.
-Yeah, it's been a rough
few months for Trump,
but at least his family is
sticking by his side.
-President Trump's niece
is coming out with
a tell-all book about her
family and revealing
she has been a key
anonymous source for reporters
looking into
the president's finances.
-Yeah, okay, maybe not.
Another Trump tell-all book.
It's crazy that,
after all these tell-all books,
there's still more to tell.
Trump's tell-all books
are starting to feel like
a 3:00 a.m. infomercial.
"But wait! There's more!"
Okay, so, the Supreme Court
ruled against him,
there's viral video about him,
and a family member
has turned on him.
I'm sure there couldn't
possibly be
any other bad news for
Trump, right?
-The FDA announced that it is
ending the emergency use of
hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine to treat
coronavirus.
-Trump was like,
"This is ridiculous.
I've been taking it every day
and I feel
coconut, tricycle, waterfall."
Trump reminded the FDA that it
only works -- [ Laughs ]
only works when you take it
with a full glass of bleach.
Yeah.
[ As Trump ]
Who's the scientist now?
What?